some opportunities to get out in
transition and get some easy baskets so
old point on time that time by the
timberwolves and the lead is 14.
love it up slot it down clark is a high
flyer some opportunities to get out in
transition and get some easy baskets so
old point on time that time by the
timberwolves and the lead is 14.
love it up slot it down clark
is a high flyer i'll let pass to
yourself for the fast break and then
john moran attracting
a couple eyes we're gonna hit the
eight-minute mark of this third quarter
series tied and a game of peace
clark drive yep and lay in clark
has been a difference maker it was
memphis leading that category 53-24
and the lead has ballooned once again
jumping inside tillman scores on the
interior
the lead is 23.
brooks hangs and hits plus one player
who impacted the play rewarded and then
right back dylan brooks
anderson
bank shot doesn't go he may have clipped
russell on his way to the basket
gives it up
laying goes for zaire williams after
each game yeah thank your opinions
swirl everywhere
flip good and a foul
dylan brooks with a chance at a
three-point play those reactions
depending on the age and the maturity of
the team
this is going to be a tall order
here in the second half we're down to a
minute 39 to go in the third
maracco's behind the back wow killer
has been a chore
[Applause]
jones
driving deuce game four will be saturday
night here in minnesota
timberwolves trying to take a 2-1 lead
as the seventh seed in the west jackson
count it for three
patrick beverly professional pest
moran cross
hang
pretty deuce for john morant plenty of
time in the shot clock jackson
rims out rebound
clark
gets it on the interior and the lead is
single digits with 10 22 to go five
fouls on jaron jackson jr he goes to the
bench at a steal beverly loses it
jones in transition
drive kick for bain takes it in for two
they've been taken out on their own
position not by what the opposing team's
good offense of rebound right there
jones
got him
now they're punching back
[Applause]
moraine met by reed double beverly
swings it oh desmond baines 90 to 88
grizzlies
minnesota one of 10 in the fourth marant
kick to the outside bane yes
sir grizzlies got in last year got beat
by utah in the first round
clark flipped it up and in
he has been big time
two minutes to play
at the target center
morant swoops in missed it follow goes
and it's clark again
and it's that man again brandon clark
step back brooks pure
timberwolves 35 to 9.
and there's a minnesota crowd
under a minute to go
double-digit lead for the grizzlies
lorette
takes it in
with the left hand